and finally new rule no cash prizes for
snitching
as i'm sure you've heard texas just
passed america's harshest abortion law
which includes the idea that anyone even
helping a woman get an abortion
like the uber driver who takes you to
the clinic can be sued by random citizen
snitches for up to ten thousand dollars
yes finally a way to tap into that vast
reserve of uber driver wealth
jesus when did west texas become east
germany even if you hate [ __ ] and love
money you have to admit bounty hunting
people who help pregnant women is a
little un-american
also
here
you're working too hard texas this is
2021.
you don't have to pay people to snitch
america's snitch nation now
they'll happily do it for free
being it's okay
it's okay
i was with this group
being a snitch now it's not a bad thing
oh it used to be used to be one of those
first one of the first things we taught
children nobody likes a tattletail but
now
virtually any public accomplishment
comes with the obligatory follow-up
snitch story a few days later like what
happened with that sad schmuck who was
supposed to host jeopardy
but fortunately the honor of game shows
was preserved when squealed team six
went through his old podcast and found
out he once used the term booth [ __ ]
whatever the [ __ ] that means
i'm sorry mike but we the perfect people
who have never made a mistake we just
can't let society be sullied by horrible
people like you buh-bye
fans of cable news will recognize the
rising journalist alexi mccammond who
was appointed editor of teen vogue but
then had to resign before her first day
when some of her high school tweets
suddenly became too much to bear tweets
like now googling how to not wake up
with swollen asian eyes
and ah you're so gay
and her resignation was endorsed by the
hierarchy of the magazine including the
senior social media manager christine
davitt good for you christine you helped
catch the zodiac killer
oh oh oh no you just ruined someone's
career for no reason same diff
funny end of the story after alexi
mccammond resigned for her innocuous
tweets someone went through christine
david's old high school tweets and
oops
seems she tweeted the n-word twice to a
white friend in 2009. buh-bye
you know this is
this is why i'm a little hopeful
that this purity purge may end because
it's starting to eat its own
espn reporter rachel nichols was a
feminist success story but when she
complained in a private telephone call
about espn's crappy long-time record on
diversity
and expressed her view that she felt
like she was being sacrificed by the
network
so they could make up for that crappy
long-time record on diversity
the call was leaked and she was toast
now in addition to the fact that a
person shouldn't have to love getting
fired
even if it does achieve more equity
this was a private call does private
mean anything anymore apparently not
even sadder this love of snitching seems
to be one of the few areas that is now
truly bipartisan
nation isn't about what side you're on
it's about this mindset where everyone
is an amateur secret policeman and
tattling is a virtue
the woke side of the internet thinks
going through someone's old myspace
account makes them part of the
resistance it doesn't it makes you a
punk
and republicans lately besides
sponsoring that new reality show texas
zygote hunters
[Laughter]
have been encouraging college students
to whip out their phones to record and
report professors who espouse leftist
ideas
as always these snowflakes fall just as
hard on the right as they do on the left
[Applause]
colleges pride themselves on being safe
spaces not for professors
at least not any who might want to
stretch young minds to think differently
and try on new ideas yeah try that at
your peril same with comedy clubs where
ever since the iphone comics have been
complaining about snitches in the
audience who rat them out
for crossing the line crossing the line
which is practically the job description
of a
comedian comics are joking constantly
even some people who aren't comics do
that
and if you're lucky enough in life to be
around people like that
i'm sure you know they can't all be gems
sometimes you get the twisties
and the joke doesn't land just right
exposing that doesn't make you noble
you're not david kaczynski the brother
of the unabomber who turned in his own
brother lest any more mail bombs go off
that was noble you know because it was
about bombs and not bombing
there's a real difference between the
unabomber and the editor of team vogue
for one thing the unabomber made some
good points
or think of edward snowden enduring
exile in russia so he could expose
unlawful government snooping noble
colonel alexander vindman exposing the
ukraine fiasco noble
that's not you taking down the host of
the ice capades
you're a loser with wi-fi and all the
time in the world to listen to long
forgotten podcasts you're not a
journalist you're just a creepy little
rat go to texas and catch a runaway
embryo
oh what you dug up a letter where jfk
said indian giver great now we can tear
down the kennedy center
you know what i don't want to live in
snitchlandia where you can't trust your
neighbors and you're always looking over
your shoulder a land of cairns and
gladys kravitz is
ruled by citizen informants where
republicans sue you for your sex life
and democrats get you fired for a
halloween costume
and then we all go home and applaud
ourselves for our courage